[Applause]
[Music]
Jamaica is a country famous for reggae
music ska music Bob Marley sprinters
such as Usain Bolt's marvellous beaches
and the Rastafarians and all of this
comes from a tiny islands with only
around three million inhabitants
[Music]
culture wise we could say Jamaica is a
giant it's likely you know someone who
is planning to spend his or her holidays
in a nice resort on some gorgeous
Jamaican Beach but there is also a
reason why you've never heard of anybody
saying oh yes I'm going to invest some
money in the lands of Bob Marley or my
company is sending me to our office in
Kingston in fact I bet nobody here could
name the Prime Minister or indeed the
currency of Jamaica yes when it comes to
international supply chains Jamaica is
as irrelevant as the food picks that
your girlfriend posts on our Instagram
the nation is as poor as Armenia or the
Philippines at least this is how it used
to be because things are now beginning
to change check this out Jamaica plant
and air and logistics hub developers
envision a trading center on the order
of Singapore Dubai and Rotterdam now to
imagine Jamaica going from laid-back
Jungle Island to the likes of Singapore
or the Netherlands might seem like a bit
of a stretch but when you think about it
it's a great solution for this
lackluster economy and Jamaica is very
well situated for this just look at this
shipping as you can see Jamaica is
located near the Panama Canal this means
that a lot of ships pass by the islands
and may need to stop and refuel or even
to store some of that cargo yes it's
possible to do both of these things in
Panama itself but it has become
increasingly expensive
this explains why Kingston has already
snagged quite a lot of shipping traffic
now add to this the fact that the Panama
Canal has recently undergone a massive
expansion and the Jamaica's only
competition our other island nations
such as Cuba and Haiti then it's clear
that Jamaica has a real shot here unlike
its island neighbours Jamaica is an
english-speaking country so any American
investor who wants to open warehouse
they couldn't have it easier great
location
cheap salaries and everything's in
English so now the question is can it
actually happen can jamaica achieve a
level of wealth on par with the dutch
well today we're going to answer these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history
[Music]
prosperity lost on the 6th of August
1962 Jamaica gained independence from
the British Empire
there was a peaceful transition and
Owens on to form the two-party
parliamentary republic in the
Westminster style which is the model
that it still has to this day the future
looked bright for Jamaica the 1960s was
a great decade for the fledgling state
the economy shifted away from
agriculture to bauxite mining tourism
low-skilled manufacturing and private
investments it boomed during the 60s and
the Jamaican economy grew at an average
of 6% per annum it seems that the
post-imperial dream was finally coming
true unfortunately things took a turn
for the worse in the 1970s though the
global economy slowed down dragging this
small island with it rising inequality
and resentment against the post-colonial
elites led a Democratic Socialist called
my core man lair to win at the elections
this meant a shift in international
relations Jamaica strengthened its Tonys
with the Soviet Union and started an
anti free-market economic agenda that's
why the country began implementing price
controls land expropriations
higher minimum wages and much more
public spending in theory many of these
reforms could have served to make a well
mr. manleigh introduced great things
like free public education maternity
leave and all kinds of social programs
but the price controls and the market
restrictions meant all those good
intentions never materialized mr.
manleigh openly praised in Cuban
Communist leader Fidel Castro didn't
exactly smooth relations over with the
United States so as a result for an
investment or but disappeared and the
middle class left the country in droves
during those years the country went into
double-digit inflation in the price
controls led to regular shortages of
even basic goods by 1980 Jamaicans had
lost patience with manly socialist
utopia that had never really
materialized and they voted him out the
right-wing Eduard Seeger took power and
then courted the US and the UK Jamaica
went from praising Castro to helping the
US with the 1983 invasion of communist
Grenada and I know what you might be
thinking right now so right after
Jamaica started doing the line with the
US everything turned around right isn't
the way things go in geopolitics well as
always reality is much more complicated
than that the crossroads of chaos
Jamaica is the place where you can
forget about your worries so much so
that no problem or as they say in the
Jamaican dialect llaman is a slogan
associated with the islands and no Yemen
doesn't mean janna but the irony is
Jamaica has lots of problems really big
problems
Jamaica extends state of emergency
travel warning over high levels of
violent crime you see to say that
Jamaica is actually an incredibly
violent country would be an
understatement
Jamaica's homicide rate is eight times
the global average in 2005 Jamaica had a
rate of 58 homicides per hundred
thousand people this was the highest in
the world for that year by 2017 it had
gone down to 57 per hundred thousand
making it only the second highest
homicide rate just below El Salvador and
just above Venezuela a former prime
minister called the crime issue a
national challenge of unprecedented
proportions problem isn't new that began
developing in the mid 1970s when both
major political parties started giving
urban gangs tons of guns and money
as you might expect lots of people were
shot to make matters worse the USA
started supplying guns to the Labor
Party and their gangs and likewise Cuba
and the USSR started supplying guns to
the national parties gangs
and yes I didn't just scramble that last
sentence in Jamaica the Labour Party is
actually the right wing party and the
National is the left-wing party by 1980
almost 800 people would be murdered in
political violence often taking place
between politically segregated
communities in urban Kingston the
political parties still support gangs to
this day although the gangs have become
less dependent on the parties and
increasingly dependent on connections in
Colombia and on international
drug-smuggling so it's no surprise that
crime rates haven't improved at all
the nature of Jamaica's economy isn't
fantastic either the islands of Jamaica
doesn't have a whole lot of resources to
offer the world's mostly triste sugar
coffee and bauxite what's more these are
all raw products not worth a whole lot
on their own and says plenty of
international competition another sector
of the economy is based on tourism which
can fluctuate suddenly and rapidly so if
not exactly a stable foundation the
issue of not having much of value to
export is made even worse when you
consider that the country also has to
import well almost everything
food medicine machinery yen a net it's
imported at the top of the list of
imports is petroleum on which Jamaica is
highly dependent resulting in some of
the highest energy costs in the world
all these factors really add up in 2017
Jamaica had a trade deficit of 4.5
billion dollars that's a lot for a
country of less than 3 million people so
now what do you get when you cross heavy
importing expensive essential items and
lingering socialist policies the answer
that would be stagflation
and yes stagflation is just on these
cool words that you get to learn about a
new watch visual politic
[Music]
it means a combination of stagnating
economic growth high unemployment rates
and inflation and after that quick
economics lesson it's time for me to ask
you to subscribe to this channel if you
haven't done so already hit that button
but let's get back to our story
you see Jamaica has experienced rampant
inflation and chronic unemployment for
about 50 years yes although Jamaica
started out strong it spends more than
80 percent of its independent history
stuck in an economic rut Jamaica thought
just attracting foreign investors to
develop tourism and industry would solve
its problems that with such high
inflation and horrific crime rates they
couldn't attract a Sudanese refugee if
they tried let alone wall street us
listen closely now because the winds of
change may just fill Jamaica's
mothballed sails a new national strategy
has been adopted and it might just be
enough not only to resuscitate Jamaica's
economy but turn it into the envy of the
seven seas Location Location Location on
the 26th of June 2016 something big
happens for the world hence the region a
very large ship across the Panama Canal
so large in fact that prior to that date
a ship of that size couldn't even get
through the canal yes that was the day
that Panama finished its long-awaited
expansion of the canal this expansion
almost doubled the canals capacity and
led to the creation of this new ship
size and new Panamax as in they ship
built to the new maximum specifications
of the canal over the next 20 months
over three thousand of these new ships
would cross the canal which has
generated news stories like this
[Music]
we're being share in the global cargo
industry is growing rapidly forbes may
20 19 and where are all these ships
going well pretty much everywhere for
example or goods going from China to
Florida or from Spain to Ecuador and
vice versa in many cases they'll pass
right by or even stop in Jamaica which
is the closest islands nation to the
canal itself so why would they stop in
Jamaica because some of these ships
might want to store their commodities
for some time before passing the Panama
Canal others might need fuel or
maintenance and Panama is already full
having an island next to it comes in
very handy and this is why Jamaica wants
to capitalize on its location and become
a transit hub nitrous for the Americas
but for the world all it needs is a
whole lot of infrastructure like ports
railways and Airport along with things
like dry docks for ship repairs now
Jamaica does have some competition from
other Caribbean nations which is putting
some pressure on them to act fast but
luckily for Jamaica their neighbors
aren't quite up to the task
Haiti and Cuba would be natural
competitors but ones Somalia's levels of
chaos since the others still communist
and facing us sanctions then this Preta
Rico US territory which is hamstrung
with its current administration and then
finally the Dominican Republic which is
pretty much the only one that could
actually compete with Jamaica
if Jamaica does pull this off it's going
to be big not just the Jamaica but on a
global level if this works it'll turn
Jamaica from a lame duck into a high
flyer imagine if this poor nation can
really become the next Singapore the
best part really does have a fighting
chance Jamaica is a mostly stable
english-speaking democracy and a member
of the Commonwealth of Nations but not
only that it's surrounded by
dysfunctional economies and borderline
failed States during the start of a
Golden Age of Caribbean shipping it's
already got some of the work done
surveying areas for feasibility of new
ports railway lines and special economic
zones the project is looking to get
about twenty eight billion dollars in
investments and the Jamaican
government's the World Bank and several
private partners have already made
pledges and contributions Jamaicans
wouldn't be the only ones getting richer
either this new infrastructure develops
more cargoes could who shipped more
quickly this would lower costs but many
populations of the world and thus
increase competition with this
competition Europeans can experience
fresher and cheaper Peruvian mangoes and
aid from Canada to Venezuela would
arrive much more quickly and be cheaper
even stuff like your speciality imported
anime body pill would be cheaper if
you're somewhere like New York Jamaica
would get a boost in the entire global
economy would too so the question now
goes over to you do you think it will
work will this new very expensive
infrastructure materialize will Kingston
become a city of the global elites like
Singapore or is Jamaica doomed to remain
in its cycle of crime and of poverty
well we'd love to hear your answer in
the comments below and please do also
visit our friends at three consider
Mediacom Ted the podcast that provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine also don't forget we publish brand
new videos every week so subscribe to
visual politic hit that Bell button so
you don't miss any posts and if you like
this video please do give us a thumbs up
and as always I'll see you next time if
you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and here's some more
of my lovely boys
check out the reconsider podcast where
we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider at WWE Chancellor Mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcast
[Music]